what's the longest word answering that
question is a little more complicated
than just counting letters
but by that metric the longest contender
is the technical name for the protein
titan it has 189
819 letters and it looks like this
[Music]
if you want to hear what it sounds like
there's actually a youtube video of that
you'll just need about three and a half
hours to spare
but there's a big asterisk at the end of
those 180 000 letters
because most linguists don't really
consider this
thing a word more like a verbal formula
the longest word in a major english
dictionary is numano
ultra microscopic silicovalcaniconiosis
which means
a lung disease caused by the inhalation
of volcanic ash but
as entry points out this was
deliberately invented to be
long which kind of puts it in the same
category as other made up mouthfuls like
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious we
could just say the longest word is
grandmother
with an infinite number of greats ahead
of it but that would be
uncharacteristically simplistic for a
linguistic show
if we're going to find a more satisfying
answer to this question we'll have to
dig deeper into what the word
word really means
if you listen to a conversation in an
unfamiliar language
it's pretty much impossible to pick out
individual words
and sometimes the same goes for your own
language if you say to your roommate i'm
gonna go to the story why anything
are you really aware of all the
individual words you're cramming
together
does your brain or your roommates
actually care where one word ends and
another begins
some languages allow you to pack whole
phrases and sentences into one word
like this turkish word that means as
though you happen to have been from
among those whom we will not be able to
easily make a maker of unsuccessful ones
in this german word that means the law
delegating the monitoring of the
labeling of beef
we can do a little of this in english in
a this technically counts as a word but
who on earth would ever call it that
kind of way we can also glue words
together to make
compound words but rarely more than two
at a time
and whether they get a space can feel
pretty arbitrary
living room space bedroom no space
tennis ball space baseball no space
that's why the whole concept of words is
sometimes considered to be primarily
orthographic which means
it only matters when you're writing it
down after all i'm not thinking about
spaces when i say the words
front yard and backyard but if i type
them spellcheck will let me know there's
a difference
so are words things that exist only on
paper and not in our minds
maybe not many linguists think that what
really makes a word a word
has to do less with how it's written and
more with how our brains process
it when you hear the sentence cheetahs
can run faster than lions
your brain analyzes the order of the
words to determine the meaning of the
sentence
but you don't need to analyze the words
themselves you just know them
cheetah is a sound you memorized a long
time ago
because everyone agreed that it means a
big cat with spots
that can run really really fast your
brain doesn't need to know why it means
that
it just does if we had to analyze
individual words the way we analyze
sentences
language would become a slog of
incomprehensibilities it's actually been
tried
in the 1600s the philosopher bishop john
wilkins proposed a universal language
in which the meanings of the words were
baked into their spellings he tried to
divide
every concept in the universe into
categories and subcategories
and assigned them all letters and slots
for example
the wilkish word for dog was zita a z in
the first lot meant animals a subsequent
i
meant four legged then t for european
canines and finally
a for the specific species dog you can
probably see why this didn't catch on
the sheer amount of mental computation
required to understand
one word would be ridiculous a child
raised to speak wilkish would have
probably tossed
all that nonsense aside and just
memorized zita
the way you and i memorized dog even the
origins of relatively new words
quickly become irrelevant there was
probably a short time in 2004 when
people were aware that a podcast was a
broadcast that you listened to on your
ipod
but our brains don't bother with all
that today it's called a podcast because
that's just what it is the
internationalization of the word is
further proof that no one really cares
where the sounds came from
this word violates the same rule that
wilkins zita did
it tries to explain its meaning within
itself
the power of words comes from the fact
that they're memorized not analyzed
because we've all agreed on a shared
mental dictionary
the actual sounds themselves can be
arbitrary no one needs to bother with
this monstrosity
because we've already agreed upon a much
easier word for the same disease
silicosis but just because something's
memorized
doesn't necessarily mean that it's short
many linguists consider compound words
with spaces like
ice cream roller coaster in high school
to be single
words because that's how our brains
interpret them
as indivisible units that we memorize to
mean a specific thing
some linguists push this idea even
further
claiming that idioms and cliches should
also count as words when we use phrases
like fly off the handle
bite the bullet or jump the shark we're
not concerned with their origins or the
literal meanings of their parts
we're just counting on our listener
having the same memorized entry in their
mental dictionary
this is why many english dictionaries
don't include that other famously long
word
anti-disestablishmentarianism originally
the word was coined for a political
movement of 19th century britain that
was opposed to
you guessed it dis-establishmentarianism
but it has
so little relevance to our lives today
that it's just not a part of our shared
vocabulary anymore
how do we judge whether a word is part
of our shared vocabulary
that really depends on who the speakers
and listeners are but if a word we're
used casually in conversation or say a
youtube video and it didn't set off on
the alarm bells
but that would be uncharacteristically
simplistic for a linguistics show
language becomes a slog of
incomprehensibilities
the internationalization of the word is
further proof that these are three of
the longest
non-spaced non-hyphenated english words
that are considered in common usage
if these slip past your ear without
slowing down your comprehension
then we can safely call these part of
your shared vocabulary
and strong contenders for the longest
commonly used word in english
to you as with all things human there
are very few hard boundaries in language
what one person considers a word might
be a phrase to someone else
and pure nonsense is someone else maybe
it's best not to think of a word as
something printed in a book with ink
or on a screen in pixels but as a unique
power of the human mind
that only works because it's shared with
everyone else
what's the longest word wow
so cool what's the longest though
these are my words coming out of my
mouth okay